sur l'actu du jour et la condamnation de
françois fillon à cinq ans de prison
dont deux ans ferme sur ces sujets arno
christophe erwan richard et vous qui
nous regardent et j'attends bien entendu
vos analyses vos commentaires vos points
de vue
[Musique]
voilà et on est tout de suite sur la
page la homepage du figaro et je salue
les internautes qui viennent de nous
rejoindre notamment chardons bleus à
l'instant avant de commencer donc je
vous propose de revenir sur
l'information de l'après midi la
condamnation de françois fillon et de
son épouse cinq ans avec sur cinq ans
dont trois avec sursis deux ferme pour
l'ancien premier ministre et candidat à
la présidentielle de 2017 plus d'un
million d'euros à rembourser pour le
couple et pour marc joulaud qui était le
suppléant de françois fillon et qui a
été également condamnée erwan le nommant
les avocats font appel ils ont ils ont
raison de faire appel
on est tous dégoûtés pas la place
d'avocat de françois fillon et de
manière générale oui ils ont raison de
faire appel dès lors qu'il reprend de
compléter la définition ça me fait tout
à fait logique
probablement pas par souci de cohérence
après que je connais pas le fond de la
décision ait pas eu connaissance de la
décision mais là elles tendent
particulièrement lourde dans le temps
pour la rencontre de françois fillon
je pense que deux personnes avaient des
doutes se fait qu'il ferait condamné
d'ailleurs lui avait honnêtement du mal
à justifier les pratiques qui lui
étaient reprochés le soin de glace pas
une surprise qu'il est un peu plus c'est
là le niveau de la peine qui peut
éventuellement surprendre mais par souci
tuant de toute façon où les avocats en
raison de raison de contester la peine
alors une condamnation particulièrement
lourdes vient de nous dire à roanne le
nord richard bouygues
est-ce que c'est quelle est votre votre
votre avis sur la question
la députée valérie boyer parle d'
acharnement à détruire le couple fillon
dans cette affaire la députée qui a été
surprise que les débats n'ont pas été
rouvert c'était la demande d
des avocats de françois fillon suite à
la révélation de pression par la
procureure est dû au parc national du
parc nationaux financier eliane houlette
je vais vous dire très très concrètement
passant je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
estimer si c'est une condamnation qui
est particulièrement lourde je ne vois
pas forcément l'acharnement qu'a eue la
députée under mais elle est aussi dans
son rôle en évoquant ce sujet puisque
quelque part c'est quelqu'un qu'elle a
connue c'est un collègue politique donc
je trouve qu'il ya voilà quelque chose
de très entendu mais j'allais dire il ya
presque déjà une condamnation qui existe
est de fait dans la dans la population
la justice vient la porte et une
condamnation de fait mais je ne sais pas
moi estimé c'est lourd ou pas lourd en
tout cas le côté acharnement je le vois
pas trop il ya toujours dans cette
histoire un rapport à la justice qui est
très particulier qui fait qu' on trouve
qu'elle en fait trop ou pas assez que
c'est trop long que ça va pas assez vite
enfin bref tout ça me laisse à penser
qu'on est un peu dans un système
habituel
même si pour le coup cette affaire est
un peu inhabituel puisqu'elle a été en
pleine campagne présidentielle elle a
mis ko un candidat qui était normalement
appelée est destiné à être peut-être le
futur président de la république voilà
mais je suis pas en capacité moins
d'estimer si c'est trop ou pas assez
christophe de voogd est ce que vous vous
êtes en capacité de le faire
ange ajoute 10 ans d'inégibilité
c'est ce à quoi le tribunal donc a
condamné françois fillon et je salue en
même temps j'en profite pour saluer les
internautes notamment babineau et
chardons bleus qui lui dit c'est
beaucoup cinq ans de prison
on précise que ces cinq ans de prison
dont trois avec sursis
oui ben écoutez je crois qu'on peut se
mettre quand même d'accord sans sens en
juger le jugement mais on peut se mettre
d'accord sur pour l'estimé le pesé
puisque en effet ce jugement correspond
aux réquisitions maximales du parquet
mêmes et même au delà puisque l'adjoint
de françois fillon si j'ai bien lu été
condamné plus lourdement que le parquet
ne l'avait demandé donc c'est lourd
de là à dire est-ce que c'est trop c'est
une autre question mais en tout cas
c'est une condamnation de repenser
pardon de votre point de vue à ce que je
veux c'est trop la nation lourde que le
problème ça va être ça va être de la
justifier dans l'opinion alors qu'il ya
vous savez ces deux nouvelles questions
qui sont apparues sur les précieux entre
guillemets sur le parquet national
financiers qui vont donc être aussi ce
j'en suis sûr matière à alimenter le
discours des avocats pour l'appel et
donc nous sommes à mon avis loin d'avoir
clos cette polémique moi je remarque
objectivement que cette polémique va
donc continuer d'autant comme vous le
savez que il reste toujours c'est
éternelles questions sur la justice
française et en particulier sur le
parquet la famille de fameuses le fameux
la fameuse maxime la femme de césar ne
doit pas être soupçonné qu'elle fois
intègre ou pas et vous le savez il ya
d'autres affaires
disons et c'est ça qui pose toujours
problème c'est la question de l'équité
qui reste quand même liée à celle de
justice les affaires ferrand les
affaires du modem
la récente affaire colère ou l'attitude
du parquet est fort différente
c'est tout ce qu'on peut observer
objectivement fort différente chardons
bleus nous dit beaucoup d'autres
parlementaires avec avait employé leur
campagne dans l'est dans les mêmes
conditions
est ce que cette réalité
arnaud benedetti est effectivement ce
que évoqué à l'instant christophe de
vogue c'est à dire les derniers
développements dans dans la sphère et
les révélations donc de la procureure
eliane houlette peuvent permettra à
fillon d'espérer un jugement plus
clément en appel peut-être je suis bien
la difficulté de vous répondre mais moi
je rejoins christophe sur les éléments
factuels c'est kelly bien évidemment il
ya la dimension judiciaire et puis la
dimension politique
quand même il faut noter une chose c'est
que cette décision intervient après
l'audition de madame houlette qui a
reconnu implicitement un certain nombre
de pressions qui ont été effectuées par
le parquet général sur le parquet
national financiers ils sont pas des
pressions qui sont neutres
même si elle ne touchait pas au fond
d'eux l'a fait elle toucher à la
procédure à la procédure dans un
calendrier politique très spécifique qui
était celui d'une campagne politique
visant à élire le futur chef de l'état
et le choix de la procédure qui a été
effectuée par le parquet national
financier c'est un choix qui a accéléré
le temps judiciaire et qui a fait que le
temps judiciaire est venue d'une
certaine manière cannibaliser le temps
politique de l'élection donc on peut se
poser des questions parce que on
constate qu'un certain nombre d'affaires
n'ont pas subi la même célérité en
matière de procédure que c'est le cas pu
subir françois fillon donc c'est ce qui
vraisemblablement aujourd'hui pose
question non seulement dans la décision
qui a été rendue cet après midi mais
également dans la façon dont françois
fillon a été traitée dans cette affaire
sur les faits moi je n'ai rien à dire en
l'occurrence les faits son crime
beaucoup par nos mais là nous dit à
l'instant la condamnation est juste au
regard des faits reprochés
mais la procédure elle peut être sujette
à caution car menés pendant la campagne
oui c'est bien le problème c'est bien le
problème c'est que à partir du moment où
vous aviez une accélération du temps
judiciaire
le choix qui a été fait c'était le choix
qui manifestement été préconisée par la
responsable du parquet national
financier c'était non pas l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire mais leur
ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
à partir du moment où vous ouvrez une
information judiciaire nécessairement
vous accélérer le temps de la justice et
vous accélérer le temps de la justice
dans un calendrier qui est un calendrier
politique qu'est le calendrier de
l'élection présidentielle donc là
indéniablement vous vous suscitez une
forme de soupçons sur la façon dont
monsieur fillon a été traitée durant ce
ce calendrier fin dans ce calendrier là
donc c'est bien ce qui pose est ce qui
pose problème aujourd'hui donc je pense
qu'il faut pas banaliser ce qui s'est
passé parce que ce qui s'est passé quand
même c'est quelque chose d'absolument
crois essentiel je veux bien que
emmanuel macron et bénéficier d'une
j'allais dire d'un élan sociologique qui
les portent et aux portes de l'elysée
mais sans sens sans cette affaire
l'élection se serait vraisemblablement
déroulé dans d'autres circonstances
donc bon après est ce que les juges ont
estimé que parce que il y avait des
faits qui leur paraissait suffisamment
grave qu'il fallait intervenir dans le
calendrier politique spécifique de
l'élection présidentielle c'est une
autre question mais est ce que
finalement c'est leur rôle en garde
v on
on va pas refaire le procès fillon mais
effectivement c'est la question qui peut
se poser vous êtes nombreux à réagir et
à débattre d'un côté il y à christophe
78 qui nous dit si tous les
parlementaires qui ont fait travailler
leur proche était puni de la même
manière les prisons seraient pleines de
parlementaires al'inverse jean-michel
nous dit en matière politique
la justice doit être intraitable en tout
cas on y revient dans un peu plus d'une
heure avec la réaction d'un proche de
l'ancien premier ministre puisque bruno
retailleau et l'inviter d'auditions
publiques et il sera interrogé sur la
sur la question et bien sûr vous avez
toutes les infos et toutes les dernières
infos les dernières réactions sur le
site du figaro au lendemain de la vague
verte les yeux étaient donc rivés sur
lui cela